We are in Section 8 on the
seventh test. We're almost
done with this book,
so let's start.
Problem number one.
If 6,700 is equal to 100 times
6k plus 7, then k equals what?
So let's divide both sides
of this by 100.
So you get 100 and you get these
two zeroes, so you get
67 is equal to 6k plus 7.
I just divided both
sides by 100.
Subtract 7 from both sides.
You get 60 is equal to 6k.
Divide both sides by 6, you
get 10 is equal to k.
That's choice C.
Problem 2.
If 3 more than n is a negative
number-- so n plus 3 is a
negative number-- that's
what that says, right?
And 5 more than n is a positive
number, so n plus 5
is greater than 0, which of
the following could be the
value of n?
So n plus 3 is negative, n plus
5 is greater, so n plus 3
has to be less than
negative 3, right?
This means that n is less
than negative 3.
How did I get that?
I subtracted 3 from both sides
of this equation, right?
If I subtract 5 from both sides
of this equation, I
would get that n is greater
than negative 5.
So you have to be greater than
negative 5 and less than
negative 3.
What's the only number that I
can think of that's that?
Well, there's a lot of numbers,
but a simple one is
minus 4, right?
Minus 4 is less than
negative 3, right?
If I draw a number line, this is
minus 3, minus 4, minus 5.
So minus 4 is less than negative
3 and it's greater
than minus 5.
So that's the answer.
Choice B.
And you can try it
out with minus 4.
Minus 4 plus 3 is minus 1.
So that works.
Minus 4 plus 5 is plus 1.
Problem three.
OK in the figure above-- OK let
me see if I can draw this.
I'll draw it big because
it looks complicated.
A line like that, a line like
that, and one like that.
They tell us this is x, this is
y, and then they tell us in
the figure above, if x is equal
to 70, so this is equal
to 70, and y is equal to 40,
so this is equal to 40, and
the dotted lines bisect the
angles with measure x and y
degrees, what is
the value of z?
OK, so the dotted lines, instead
of drawing dotted
lines, I'm going to draw green
lines, so this green line will
bisect this angle, so it
goes right in between.
So if it bisects the angle, what
is the measure of this
angle right here?
Well, it's going to be half of
this angle that it bisected.
So this whole thing
is 70, so this is
going to be 35 degrees.
Similarly, this other green line
is going to bisect this
y-- oh, I thought I was
using the line tool.
This other green line is going
to bisect y right here, right?
So it bisects it.
So if it bisects it, what's
this angle going to be?
Well, it's going to be half of
angle y, and they tell us
angle y is 40.
I wrote that.
I just wrote over it.
So this has to be 20
degrees, right?
Because it's half
of the full y.
And they say, what is
the values of z?
Well, z is just this
whole thing.
So it's this angle plus this
angle, so it's 55 degrees.
And that's choice E.
Problem four.
A piece of fruit is to
be chosen at random
from a basket a fruit.
The probability that the piece
of fruit chosen will be an
apple is 2/5.
So the probability of an
apple is equal to 2/5.
Which of the following could not
be the number of pieces of
fruit in the basket?
Could not be.
So the secret here is you take
2/5 and whatever 2/5 is times
the number of fruit, right?
2/5 times the number of
fruit has to equal
the number of apples.
And implicitly, there's not
going to be a fractional
number of apples
in the basket.
You can't pick up a
piece of an apple.
So this is going to have to be
an integer, the number of
apples, right?
So if 2/5 times some number is
going to be an integer, then
this number has to be
divisible by 5.
It makes sense, you know?
If there are 10 fruit,
then this is going
to be equal to 4.
If there are 20 fruit, then
this is going to be what?
What's 2/5 of 20?
It's going to be 8.
But if there were 6 fruit, or
if we thought the number of
fruit was 6, 2/5 times
6 is 12/5.
That means that there are
2 and 2/5 apples.
That's not right.
So what we have to find is the
number of fruit, and it has to
be some number divisible by 5.
And if you look at the choices,
they give you 20,
that's divisible by 5.
35 is divisible by 5.
Choice C, 52.
That's not divisible by 5.
And then the other two choices,
70 and 80 are
divisible by 5.
So only C is not
So that's our choice.
That could not be the number
of fruit in the basket.
And you could figure it out.
If there were 52 fruit, and 2/5
were apples, you'd get a
fractional number of apples.
And that's not cool.
Next problem.
Problem five.
A square and an equilateral
triangle have equal
perimeters.
If the square has sides of
length 3, what is the length
of one side of the triangle?
So a square and a triangle
have equal perimeters.
And the square has--
what does it say?
It has sides of length 3.
So 3, 3, 3, 3.
So what's this perimeter?
It's 3 plus 3 plus 3 plus 3.
That's 12.
Perimeter is 12.
Well, this triangle is also
going to have a perimeter of
12, but it's going to have it
amongst 3 equal sides, right?
Because there's only 3
sides of a triangle.
So it's going to have 12 divided
by 3, so it's going to
have to be 4, 4, and 4,
so one side of the
triangle has length 4.
That's choice C.
Problem six.
We'll do it here.
If x is equal to negative 1 and
k is greater than 0, which
of the following has
the greatest value?
OK, so choice A is 2
times k times x.
So k is positive, x is minus
1, so this is going to
be less than 0.
So this is going to be a
negative number, right?
And so we know that's probably
not going to be the answer.
So if we look at all of the
choices, the only positive
answers, the only positive
choices, are going to be the
ones where I raise x to an
even exponent, right?
Because if I raised x to an odd
exponent, like let's see,
choice C, choice C
is 6k x cubed.
And that's equal to 6k times
minus 1 cubed, right?
Because x is minus 1.
So that's going to
be minus 6k.
And we know k is a
positive number.
I mean, really, you could just
ignore the k's, really.
k is just a positive number.
It's just kind of a
scaling factor.
And they all have k in them.
So you just have to worry about
the coefficient in the x
terms. So one thing we can--
if x has an odd exponent on
it, it's going to be a negative
number, so that's not
going to be the greatest
value.
So there are only two that
have x with a-- so
you have 4k x squared.
That's choice B.
And then you have choice D,
which is 8k x to the fourth.
Well, in both of these cases,
x squared is equal to 1.
Negative 1 squared is 1.
Negative 1 to the fourth is
also equal to 1, right?
And if k is positive,
what's bigger?
8k or 4k?
Well, 8k is going
to be bigger.
As I said, they all have k in
them so you could kind of
ignore k because it's
a positive number.
So the answer is choice D.
I'll see you in the
next video.